-Our first guest is the
co-founder of She Se Puede
a new digital
lifestyle community.
She's also
an Emmy Award-winning actor,
director, and producer who stars
in NBC's "Superstore,"
which premiers on October 29th
Let's take a look.
-Hey, any update on when you two
lovebirds are moving to Cali
-Well, um, with all of thi
craziness,
they've pushed my start date
so it's all a little
up in the air --
just like this virus.
Just kidding.
It's not airborne.
Well, we don't know that.
It could be. Anyway --
-Oh, my God.
Hey, everyone's overreacting
I mean, no friggin' way
I'm missing out
on spring break this year.
-Actually, the latest articles
are saying
that washing your hands
isn't enough.
We should be wearing
face coverings,
avoiding large groups.
-Like, say, 50-plus employee
and an endless stream
of customers?
-That sounds like here.
-Please welcome back to the show
America Ferrera.
It's so nice to see you again.
How are you?
-Hi, Seth. I'm doing well.
Thank you.
-And congratulations
are in order.
We've talked about the fac
that you have a son.
And now since the last tim
you were here,
you have a daughter, correct
-I do.
She was born in May,
kind of at the top of
quarantine.
And she's 5 months old now
-So I would imagine it's sort of
a pro and con situation.
The con is, was it scary to,
you know,
obviously have to go through
the medical care involved
with having a baby
during a pandemic?
With the pro being,
you're home
and you got to spend, obviously,
a lot of quality time,
I imagine.
-Yeah. Yes.
I mean, having the baby
is an isolating time anyway.
So it's nice to know I'm not
missing out on any fun anyway.
But it was a little bit
nerve-wracking, yes,
in the beginning to not be sur
what the situation
was going to be like
in hospitals.
And, you know, things were
changing on a day-to-day basis
So, I just had to kind
of breathe through it
and, you know,
hope for the best.
But, you know, we --
we're all happy and health
and that's all anyone
can ask for, so...
we got lucky.
-Congratulations.
I do have to ask how --
I guess it's about a two-yea
difference with you kids?
How is your son reacting to hi
little sister so far?
-You know what was great i
we were home with him
for so many weeks before
she came that I think
he was actually relieved tha
out attention was not on him
He was like, "Get another --
you know, "Get another focus
Mom and Dad."
So he's been actually grea
and has not taken anything
out on her,
which, I guess, is, you know
a good sign.
-That is a very good sign.
I also want to congratulate yo
for this new platform
you launched.
This is basically for --
I guess, how would you
describe it?
The Latina community?
Is that an accurate way
to describe it?
-Yeah, so She Se Puede
is a new online home,
lifestyle and community
for Latinas by Latinas.
And it's meant to empower us t
live in our full power
and lead in our families and our
communities and in the country
It's a mindset that Latinas ar
ready and poised to conque
in every aspect of their life.
In culture and in civic action
and politics, as well.
-This both seems like
a good idea
and one that probably should
have happened already.
How did you come about being
in a position to launch it
-Well, there certainly have been
a number of -- of platform
existing to empower
and inspire Latinas.
She Se Puede came about --
Eva Longoria and myself
and eight other incredible
women from -- from organizin
and activism and from business
and from tech and research
came together to say,
what is missing for Latina
in this conversation
about our empowerment?
Because, you know, campaigns
and candidates
coming around two months
before an election
to knock on our door and say
"Your vote matters"
is not cutting it.
It's not going to lead to
the true empowerment of Latina
using their power
and full force.
And what's missing is community.
And for us to not just hea
that our votes count,
but that our lives count,
that our joy and our struggles
and our goals, and that ever
aspect of our life matters
And to celebrate the incredibl
contributions
that we're making
across the board
in every part of our
country.
You know, one quick fact
is that Latinos are 18%
of the population in the U.S.,
but we are 34%
of essentials workers.
That in and of itself lets
you know that contribution
that the Latino community is
making in this country
that all too often are eithe
completely invisible
in our culture,
and at worst are portrayed
in really harmful ways
and with harmful stereotypes
So we have new story to tell
which is all about the badasse
that we currently are
and the power that we hold
in our Latina community,
and the difference we can make
when we are truly empowere
and acting from
that empowerment.
-This is obviously something
you've been
passionate about
for a long time.
It must be exhilarating to hav
a place to put this energy
-Well, yes, it's amazing,
and the response is amazing.
The fact that we launched this
and very quickly had
tens of thousands of peopl
in our community
hungry for this.
And especially in this year.
Obviously we're 20 something
days away from an election
where everything is at stake
and Latinas
will be the deciders
in every state
across this country.
In key states that matter fo
the outcome of this election
like Florida, Arizona,
Wisconsin, and Michigan,
Latina voters can be decider
up and down the ballot.
And so we all need to be
concerned with the empowerment
and the resourcing of
Latino voters
and specifically
Latina voters,
who on their own make up
the margin of victory
and defeat in so many states
across the country.
-I also want to leave by askin
you about "Superstore."
You are going to only do
two episodes this season.
It's bittersweet.
It's the 100th episode
is your last one,
which really speaks to
the accomplishment of this show.
It's very hard to stay
on television that long.
How do you feel about saying
goodbye to a family
that you've been a part of
for so long?
-Well, it's been a pretty long
goodbye.
I was supposed to say goodby
back in March,
but then we got shut down
for quarantine.
So, you know, the joke is
that I've just, like,
said goodbye 500 times.
I've had three
last table reads.
Like, the cast couldn't be
more ready to just, like,
get rid of me.
They've said goodbye already
But I -- you know,
I love the show.
I had such an amazing
five years.
I got to work with this
incredible cast.
I got to be
an executive producer.
I got to direct.
And it's been such an amazin
five years.
The show -- I'm so proud o
the show, of what it is,
of how beloved it is by
its audience, and I --
You know, it's always
bittersweet to go,
but I just couldn't be mor
proud of the five years
that I spent on "Superstore.
-Well, congratulations
on that.
Congratulations on
everything else.
It's always such a delight
to see you.
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you so much.
-Please visit
shesepuede.org
for more information
on the organization.
And "Superstore" premieres
October 29th right here on NBC